في المقابل اكد عمدته نوفاكا خوفك الموالي
لروسيا قصف القوات الاوكرانيه للسد من
خلال عدد من الضربات على محطه كخوف سكايا
لتوليد الطاقه الكهرومائيه مما ادى الى
تدمير الصمامات التي تتحكم بضخ المياه عبر
السد واضاف انه نتيجه للقصر الاوكراني
بدات المياه تتدفق من السد باتجاه مجرى
النهر
محطه نوفايا كخوفكا الكهرومائيه بنيت مع
مراعاه امكانيه تعرضها لضربه نوويه وضربات
الارهابيه متعدده في الساعه الثانيه بعد
منتصف الليل دمرت الاجزاء الموجوده فوق
سطح الماء نتيجه لذلك بدات المياه بالتدفق
دون سيطره نقوم الان بكل الاجراءات في
حاله تطلب الامر اجلاء جزء قليل من
المدنيين في نحو 300 منزل لا توجد حاله
كارثيه او تهديد الخطر الوحيد هو مشكله مد
شبه جزيره القرم بالمياه من بحيره السد